welcome back some people call it turkey
neck or
double chin we're talking about loose
skin and our next guest
hazing has a non-surgical solution
welcome back
brittany from the jazzy wellness it's
great to see you so tell everyone what
is the
ultrasound skin lift
the ultrasound skin lift uses a
ultrasound
to penetrate down into the muscle to
tighten the skin from the inside out
so what areas of the body does it treat
anywhere we can do the face the neck the
chest or anywhere on the body
look at these results that we see here
on the screen these before and after
pictures are stunning
how does this whole process work because
this is non-surgical how does it all
work it's just a one-time treatment
we use three different levels to target
different areas so
one goes down to the muscle to tighten
the muscle and that's for lifting and
tightening one goes to the adipose
tissue
so that's for deep wrinkles and one just
goes to the surface skin and that is for
fine line
now a treatment like this and these
results that we're seeing how long does
a treatment take how long is a session
typically up to an hour depending on
what area we're doing
but it's pretty quick and then you said
that you start seeing this is only
one treatment needed to get these
results that we're looking at
yep and so how does the process work
someone's watching right now
they want to come down and see you do
you guys offer a consultation to walk
them through the process
yep you can come in for a free
consultation we'll take a look at the
area
you can tell us your concerns we will
recommend what area we think you should
do
and then it's just a one-time treatment
and we'll do a follow-up with you in six
months
one of the big things that you guys
treat is we call the turkey neck that
loose skin
under your neck someone comes in they
have the treatment done they get the
results how long
are those results lasting for us up to
five years
five years from one session yes
okay you gotta be honest on this next
question pain level talk to me
is there pain level that goes into this
it depends on the person
i would say it feels kind of like a just
a warm sensation
most of my patients fall asleep honestly
and so i come in there in the morning
with turkey neck i do my treatment 45
minutes over lunch time i'm a whole
different person come dinner time
same day we'll see some textural
improvement but it's over the next six
months that you just continuously
tighten
so you always every time you're on the
show you guys have a special for us what
kind of specials do you have today
so right now the first 10 callers will
get a free consultation and 40
off of their service i love it brittany
thank you so much for joining us we
appreciate it
and as you said well the jazzy wellness
first off you guys are located at 900
south valley view boulevard suite 100
you can find them online at
thejazzywellness.com
and take advantage of this special deal
first 10 callers receive
40 percent off the non-surgical facelift
mercedes